welcome back everybody we have Daniel
Radcliffe and Jane Krakowski on the line
they are both I'm actually in the new
unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt
Kimmy versus the Reverend now on Netflix
come check it out because the new Kimmy
Schmidt episode is about making choices
and because Twitter forces tough
questions upon us every day
Daniel Jane and I are going to deal with
some of those very tough choices and a
little segment called Kelly's Korn
Twitter questionnaire none of the most
liked and retweeted questions on Twitter
in the last month then we will all get
to answer so our first Twitter question
is from at the year of Elin your
quarantine nickname is how you feel
right now plus the last thing you ate
out of the cupboard
okay Jane you go ladies first go ahead
oh okay
mine would be hopeful nothing's my guess
would be like contented honey roasted
almonds it's quite long overwhelmed red
velvet cake but you know I usually do
feel overwhelmed when you eat too much
of it adds a friend to I obviously have
it all right so next question next to
the question is from at gif Mario who is
your racer of choice and Mario Kart on
Nintendo 64 Daniel what's yours
you're the game uh I was never very good
at it but I think the character that I
always liked playing as the most was
goofy I love you seems like cute and fun
yeah I know she's cool that would have
been mine no she's mine
what's yours Jane have you ever played
Mario Kart he's never played it
I somehow did not get into the video
game thing at all and I know with kids
their kid pressure my son hasn't really
gotten into Mia either I'm sort of like
trying to so I'll take you oh she -
she's awesome
Yoshi's it's a fun one okay though this
next one was supposed to buy at moving
sideways you are quarantined with the
first artist you saw in concert who is
it Dania we'll let you go first
well the first band I went to see was
the strokes which is quite cool
but I might be actual like real answer
which is that a concert I was taken to
one who's like 10 would be better voice
so be me in the metal voice pretty cool
yeah okay you're cool whatever stream
tastes a little more Jersey where I was
raised
[Laughter]
your record team's gonna be a good time
[Laughter]
honestly can't remember and this sounds
funny I can't remember it was either it
was this is gonna sound funny but it was
either the toady's which is my favorite
band of all time it's a Texas band their
alternative or it's Celine Dion so I
don't know which one but I think she'd
be a hell of a good time in the
quarantine cuz you seen her on stage but
she is crazy funny subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going